kyle is with us in tulsa hi kyle welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show sure what's up
yeah me and my girlfriend have been
going out for over a little over a year
now and she has two kids and we've
talked about marriage a little bit and
I'm trying to figure out I am dead on my
own so I'm trying to figure out how to
like prepare my life my future that way
they can have a good future too and you
know make sure everything works out okay
you said you have debt is that what
you're said yeah yeah yeah I do okay how
much debt do you have it's about
seventeen thousand okay and how much
debt does she have she has roughly about
the same CL he has a car and what does
she make
she makes 25 25 year what a minute
what do you make the same yeah we work
at the same place you both make 25 yeah
so you have a if you were married you'd
have a fifty thousand dollar income with
thirty four thousand dollars worth of
debt that I understand that right yes
okay and when would you be talking about
getting married I'm not sure I mean
that's kind of up in the air right now
I'm just yeah trying to think through it
okay well I mean the main thing is not
whether or not you have debt it's
whether or not you are in agreement on
how you're going to handle money meaning
that we're going to be in agreement that
we're both going to attack this debt
with a vengeance and we're going to get
rid of it so that we can build wealth so
that we can have a great retirement and
these kids can go to college and so on
how old are you I'm 25
how old is she 22 and she has two kids
what ages yep
four-year-old in a six month old
in a six-month-old okay yes
so she's recently gone through a divorce
yeah breakup yeah it's kind of messy huh
mm-hmm okay all right well what I would
tell you is this you want to make sure
that you the two of you sit down with a
pastor and a marriage counselor and get
some detailed in-depth family counseling
because you're going to be an instant
dad yeah and and these little kids don't
come with a training manual yeah and so
you know you and she you know you want
to make sure that you're gonna be able
to speak into the raising of these kids
and if mama bear rises up and says
you're not able to speak to that
and yet you're paying the bills and
living and married and so forth that's
going to cause problems in your marriage
so you know the management and the the
encouragement and the discipline and the
nurturing of the kids can become a real
sticking point when they will in a
blended family and so you want to make
sure that you guys have worked all of
that through and that you've worked
through the money decisions we're gonna
stay out of debt we're gonna save and
invest we're going to get out get rid of
this debt we're going to be on a budget
together we're going to have a plan
here's the reason I'm bringing that up
the data that we have from doing this
for 30 years is the number one cause of
divorce in North America today's money
fights and money problems there are four
things a young couple need to be in
agreement on and if they're in agreement
on these four things the data points
tell us they have a high success rate in
their marriage a very high success rate
number one is money
number two is kids number three is
religion and number four is dealing with
the in-laws the extent the extent
family because there's because there's
crazy in every family and you got to
know how to deal with it okay yeah and
so if you guys can the two of you can in
your pre-marriage counseling get a real
flow chart a real template on how to
deal with the kids that you're both
going to be in agreement
you're gonna love those kids like
they're your own and you're gonna be
consequently speaking into their nurture
and their discipline as if you were
their biological dad alright and you're
going to set that plate up you're going
to put that on the plate ahead of time
the same thing with the money we're
going to combine our money we're going
to be an agreement on what we're going
with the money we're going to be in
agreement on our religious affiliations
we're gonna be in agreement on dealing
with in-laws because in other words you
can't let mother-in-law get between you
as an example that kind of thing happens
all the time if you can get those four
areas covered all the data tells us you
have about a 90 percent success ratio
with your marriage one of those four
things is where almost everyone trips up
and you got two of them right now that
are bothersome so ya really need to
address them you have a very young
fiancee with very young children
recently coming out of a toxic situation
danger danger
yeah okay and so take their time and I'm
not saying you dot not to love the woman
I'm not saying she's not a great woman
she probably is all that's fine but just
take your time and get detailed in-depth
free marriage coaching and counts okay
and by the way people that do in-depth
pre-marriage counseling have a very high
success rate of marriage because good
good marriage counseling done ahead of
time good pre-marriage counseling will
keep a bad marriage from happening right
it'll ruin it it'll ruin the engagement
if it's good stuff if the engagement
needs to be ruined and if there's too
much toxicity and you're not going to
survive anyway it'll blow it up and
that's what you want to do is I mean
tough tough discussions you want to have
those before you get married not after
they're there
me marriage is tough enough when you got
everything lined up but when it's not
lined up oh my goodness can you have a
mess so hey there you go thanks for
joining us